this video was brought to you by audible
hi welcome to the third cold fusion
episode for this week
last time we took a look at tesla's
announcements for a 25 000
car and improved battery technology and
manufacturing
but today we're going to look at
something completely different
in a stanford school of medicine study a
drug coded carbon nanotube reduced
plaque buildup in mice arteries without
causing harmful side effects
so you might be thinking so what who
cares
well this is probably why you should
cardiovascular disease
is the world's leading cause of death
with almost 18 million people
each year dying from it it accounts for
a third of all
deaths and one-third of these deaths
occur prematurely in people under 70.
in fact the frequency of this disease is
a hundred percent
in people over 65 it's just a matter of
severity
the disease can start from childhood and
can be silently building for decades
so this story is important to everyone
in this episode we're going to take a
look at some new research out of
stanford that uses carbon nanotubes to
solve this problem
it's super interesting stuff so let's
take a look
you are watching cole fusion tv
[Music]
arthrosclerosis which leads to
cardiovascular disease
and other diseases is caused by the
buildup of fats
calcium cholesterol which is a waxy
substance within the blood
and other materials building up in and
on your artery walls
this mass is called plaque in some cases
the plaque can burst triggering a blood
clot
strokes heart attacks organ failures and
a whole host of problems can occur from
the buildup of plaque in our arteries
the exact cause of the disease is
unknown the risk factors include
high cholesterol levels diabetes obesity
and an unhealthy diet so after
understanding these facts
it's a reminder to look after yourself i
know it was to me
the treatment of the established disease
may include medications to lower
cholesterol
or blood thinners such as aspirin but
for late stage patients
this has only a limited efficacy a lot
of medical treatments
often focus on alleviating the symptoms
but don't do much to get at the
underlying problem
although treatments are getting better
they target the risk factors
but don't treat the accumulation of
disease cells
and inflammation with within artery
walls
newer treatments have come about that
suppress the plaque buildup by using
antibodies
these antibody treatments cause problems
by clearing healthy tissue as well
which leads to complications in other
words
these new methods aren't precise enough
for the job
it's a tricky issue and it's time for
some new thinking for this problem
what if there was something that had the
potential to stop the disease
and even reverse the plaque buildup the
solution
may lie in an unexpected place carbon
nanotubes
[Music]
when people mention carbon nanotubes
images of some crazy material from a
marvel comic or something spring to mind
but the thing is it basically is there
it's a remarkable material
they're essentially rolled up sheets of
graphene a single layer of carbon atoms
thick
just rolled up into a tube so it has all
the amazing properties of graphene
just in tube form carbon nanotubes were
discovered all the way back in 1993
by two independent research teams
recently carbon nanotubes have been
experiencing a surprisingly strong
interest in the medical field for the
purposes of drug delivery
unlike conventional drugs they can
target very specific cells and regions
without having the side effect of
harming healthy cells
so here's how it works firstly the issue
with plaque is that the problematic
cells within the artery
give off a don't destroy me signal this
signal stops the immune system's waste
removal cells from destroying them
we'll call this signal a cloaking signal
because it's easier to think of the
problematic cells as hiding
interestingly that same signal is found
on the surface of many types of cancers
allowing them to escape detection and
multiply
so here comes the solution researchers
first developed a nanotube about two to
three nanometers in diameter
for reference a nanometer is about the
size of a dna
or a thousand times smaller than a
bacteria or
one hundred thousand times thinner than
the width of a sheet of paper
these tiny nanotubes were then modified
in a solution to make them biocompatible
and finally they were bonded with
special dye so that they could be
tracked
and their location measured the
nanotubes were then loaded with a
molecule
that turns off that pesky cloaking
signal this is all shown here in figure
1b
the red cy 5.5 is the dye that makes the
nanotubes visible
the shp1i is the molecule that turns off
the cloaking signal
it's pretty cool right
unlike the existing antibody treatments
these nanotubes were taken up by white
blood cells
the white blood cells naturally end up
in inflammatory sites
such as artery plaque once they were
inside the plaque
the white blood cells now recognized the
problematic cells and destroyed them
we'll discuss the promising results of
the study in a bit
dr smith one of the authors of the paper
explains
quote we found that we could stimulate
the macrophages
and just a note that means destroy cells
or white blood cells in our case
two selectively eat dead cells and dying
cells
these inflammatory cells are the
precursor cells to atherosclerosis
that just means the plaque buildup in
the arteries that are part of the cause
of heart attacks
so basically the drug carried by the
nanotubes
shuts off the cloaking signal so the
white blood cells can recognize that it
should spring into action
and get rid of the problematic cells
which are the dead cells in cell debris
the kind of cells that make up the core
of plaque deposits
as the study states once the cloaking
mechanism is shut off
the white blood cells quote cause the
plaques to eat themselves from the
inside out
thus reducing their size and stabilizing
their growth
end quote it's almost like
giving the body a nudge to fight against
plaque buildup in arteries
which it usually would ignore
so here are the results the researchers
found that the nanotherapy
reduced plaque by 40 in both male and
female
mice with less advanced plaque buildup
and it reduced plaque by 20
in mice with advanced plaque buildup you
can see that here in this image
what you're looking at here is a
cross-section of an artery on the left
is the control group with nanotubes
containing just the dye
and on the right is nanotubes that
include the molecule that inhibits the
cloaking signal
the researchers discuss more quote
because the white blood cells that took
the nanotubes went to artery plaque
rather than healthy tissue the
nanotherapy avoided side effects such as
organ damage we were able to constrain
the uptake into just the cells we want
there's a general rule of treatment the
more targeted you get
the fewer side effects you have it's an
exciting development
not only for cardiovascular disease but
also for cancer
the study also found quote minimal to no
accumulation
in the healthy aorta bone marrow heart
lung gut fat muscle and kidneys
end quote i think that's a good sign the
authors call these results
a key translational barrier for this
class of drugs
the researchers add quote but best of
all we didn't see any significant
toxicities
interestingly carbon nanotubes have also
proved safe
and don't cause the immune system to go
crazy in primates
so eventually the idea is that a
solution containing the nanoparticles
will be iv injected into a patient and
then will flow through their bloodstream
before we continue i just want to thank
this episode sponsor
audible is the leading provider of
spoken word entertainment and audiobooks
ranging from best sellers news business
and self-development
if you're busy and don't have time to
sit and read audible is a great way to
enjoy content
while you're doing something else and
even if you just need to relax before
bed
it's a great way to stay entertained or
learn knowledge
speaking of which my book new thinking
which covers the story of humanity
through the lens of technology is
available
on audible from the steam engine to
nikola tesla
to the iphone and artificial
intelligence new thinking is the story
of what drove the inventors of our
modern world
to do what they did and how all of their
contributions link together
new thinking is rated the ninth best
book on technology history by book
authority
after listening to it you'll be able to
look around you and understand how
pretty much everything came to be
if you want to listen to new thinking or
any other audio books
go to audible.com cold fusion or text
cold fusion to 500 500 for a 30-day free
trial right so where were we
yeah scientists loaded carbon nanotubes
with an anti-cloaking molecule
that makes artery plaque eat itself
so how did they attach the drug that
switches off the cloaking mechanism
to the carbon nanotube well it was done
via a process
called pie stacking as depicted here
interestingly there is some control over
how aggressively you want the drug to be
delivered
the larger the diameter the stronger the
attachment of the molecule to the carbon
nanotube
this method was first used in 2007
so i had a question when i was first
looking into the therapy i asked myself
well this is all well and good but what
happens to the nanotubes once they've
done their job
do they just float around forever well
as it turns out
other studies have revealed that carbon
nanotubes are eliminated by immune cells
in a matter of weeks
these experiments which are cited by the
stanford study were carried out in 2010
and 2016 respectively
so i think this is also very exciting
and could save a lot of people from an
early death
but these are very early days and we
should be cautiously optimistic
but seeing that this disease is the
number one killer on the planet i'm
still very encouraged by such
preliminary research
i'm interested to know your thoughts
especially those of you who have been
diagnosed with a vascular condition
let me know in the comments if you want
to see a similar video on nanotherapy
that kills cancer
i'll leave a link to that video below
so that's just about it for me if you do
want to see anything on science
technology
business or history definitely subscribe
to cold fusion
you will get to see some interesting
topics like this one and many others
anyway my name is tagogo and you've been
watching cold fusion
and i'll see you again next week for the
next episode
next time we'll be taking a look at the
history of adobe software
did you know that in 1993 one of the
co-founders was kidnapped at gunpoint
it's an interesting story so stay tuned
for that one
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]
cold fusion it's me thinking
you